ronnie scott's in london is a
world-renowned music venue it opened its
doors in 1959
and has hosted the biggest names in jazz
ever since but recently it welcomed
another kind of musician people who want
to give their instruments away
ian lee visited the club to find out why
it's the end of the road for ron eaves
family heirloom
ron's dad played this trumpet during
world war ii but it's been collecting
dust for decades why did you want to
donate it here versus selling it on ebay
to help a child to learn an instrument
would be great you know definitely i had
no
compunction whatsoever about bringing it
here he brought the instrument to ronnie
scott's one of the world's most iconic
jazz clubs what kind of legends have
graced this stage there have been so
many
anyone from miles davis dizzy gillespie
the great
ella fitzgerald
hundreds of folks delivered their warm
beat up and sadly at times brand new and
unwanted instruments during the club's
latest charity drive
i'm gonna say flute and maracas what are
you saying
oh well oh do you have any there's two
things in here
someone will be very happy with this
who are the kind of people bringing in
instruments anyone from the young or old
person who bought an instrument during
the lockdown and decided that they
weren't going to be this big star
to
people who bought instruments years ago
and you know haven't had the chance to
practice for one reason or the other
[Music]
the instrument amnesty is in its third
year and distributes the donations to
schools and charities introducing kids
around the world to music open so many
doors to you when you have access to
music education and especially if you're
living in an um underprivileged area or
are disadvantaged for one reason or the
other so it's it's it's an escape it's
an escape for a lot of these children
and this is what a successful drive
looks like it looks like every nook and
cranny there's an instrument i mean you
could trip over them some of these
donated instruments need a little tlc
volunteers restore them to make sure
they're pitch perfect i remember the
person bringing this in and i looked at
it and thought
there's no way you can do anything with
it but it can be fixed apparently before
shipping them out so for these people
it's kind of like the music died the
music died a little bit but they want
the music to live on that's the most
important part for cbs saturday morning
ian lee london
so nice pass along the music love it all
these things people picked up during the
pandemic
what to do with it and then when i'm not
so good at that yes